to software developers proved they can
remotely seize control of a moving car
the hackers demonstrated this for Wired
magazine to show the dangers out there
they were able to disable the
accelerator and brakes even though they
were ten miles away they even what less
importantly turned on the radio blasted
the air-conditioning struction they
posted their picture on it's a Fiat
Chrysler they posted their picture on
the control unit the display unit of the
UConnect system which I thought was
probably too freaked out the driver as
well too freaked out the driver who's
there buddy I believe writer or editor
at Wired but this just shows you what's
possible and with a lot of modern cars
you could even take over the steering
because unfortunately a lot of steering
has gone to computerize electronic
steering so I hear we have video of this
guy losing control is there any way to
turn that off like can you turn off your
responder transponder or whatever not
turning off the car you know so it's
basically something that that needs to
be dealt with and the problem is it's
going to get worse and worse and worse
as autonomous driving yeah with the
driverless cars exactly like it'll make
me think again about putting my kids in
a driverless car this is why I want to
buy a fully analog car you know I don't
even want what's the last fully analog
car out there is there one they're very
difficult to find a car I mean without
even electronic fuel injection I mean
carburetors rack-and-pinion yeah you
know abs no traction control